our first in-studio guest of the week
and uh i've known this man for a very
long time since he first arrived at the
worldwide leader in sports a year after
i arrived there he is now the
chief trends officer of caesar's
sportsbook trey wingo here on the rich
eisenshow good to see you trey yeah good
to see you brother um it's been a bit uh
the good news is i'm the first guest of
the week which means we can only go up
from here that's not true so the bar is
set low so everyone else can climb above
it is that the uh is that the trend that
you're sensing
i mean because it's kind of the trend of
my life rich
i'm good with it trey
good to see you here brother good to see
you man yeah how long have you been here
already or do you've got does your kids
still live out here yeah both our kids
live out here
my parents are in palm springs so i got
here i flew in from maui on
of course you did tuesday of course you
did of course you did oh did i say that
i'm sorry
i just looked down
i didn't mean to drop that i was too bad
[Music]
i did not see him on the island he was
still back in uh okay in the confines of
lovely northwest connecticut buried
under 17 feet of snow but you are not
that is a factual state
[Laughter]
which you are not i guess i do not
believe it was snowing in uh in maui
hawaii okay by the way
this is a great uh quote um i just saw
joe burrow just said this moments ago he
was asked on his zoom today
for advice to younger athletes
he said quote don't have a workout and
then go post it on instagram and then go
sit on your butt for four days work in
silence i love that that but that's him
right that's who he is right like that's
him to his core there was somebody else
god it drives me crazy i remember who it
was
oh it was uh it was devonte adams who
basically said hey all you wide
receivers quit posting workouts run
routes right just run routes run routes
do your work and then when you're
successful because you put in the work
then people will see what you've done
don't don't put out workouts just go do
your stuff i mean and and his ascendancy
i can't
you know i can't see
another one like it now i know there's
the connection to brady in terms of year
two and
you know um out of nowhere if you will
but burrows out of nowhere happened at
the collegiate level yeah and we've
never seen somebody take the reins of an
organization that needs someone to take
the reins first overall
after having done it at the collegiate
level in a manner that nobody's ever
done at 60 touchdowns like this is one
of the most meteoric rises we've ever
seen yes remember i mean urban chose
dwayne haskins over joe burrow i mean
like and that might have been the right
call at the time i had 50 touchdowns he
played he played very well at ohio state
not to defend urban mode
i mean
that's an impossible you don't want to
kick somebody when they're down wait a
minute hold on a minute i did i just i
said no you want to dunk on him
right instead of kicking no but i mean
he did
and and my alma mater i think
did have something to do with that
because when jt barrett went down in the
big house i remember sitting there
thinking okay we got ohio state right
where we want him and then and then
dwayne haskins came off the bench and
looked phenomenal sucker came out of
nowhere he did
but uh thank you thank you
uh no but the joey thing isn't like
you know this as someone who has done
the draft and all that kind of stuff you
find all these little notes right you
find all these little nuggets
and one of the coolest things i remember
from the 2020 draft packet
uh that my great researcher jim carr who
worked with me at espn is now part of
the caesars operation with me jimmy
you're the best i love you
um he found this note that they did like
a psychological evaluation of joe burrow
and the guy said his disassociative
properties are off the charts
in other words in a in a stressful
situation
he responds like a first responder like
all the the bleep that's going on and
terrible it doesn't affect him and he
said in fact it's so off the charts he's
either going to be someone like a first
responder or perhaps a very good
criminal
yeah like you know like
whatever it is
he could use those properties for good
or for evil right right and he's used
him very well for good at this point
he's like dexter just like you know
right like yeah he can remove himself
from anything
and steal that ice watch and still sort
of accomplish what he wants to
accomplish so he's in the super bowl
he'll either be dexter or dexter
lawrence is that what you're saying
pretty much there sure super bowl mvp
ladies and gentlemen so
with
borrow i couldn't help again but think
that i was you know in sofi
prior to kickoff of the nfc championship
game and they're showing the afc
championship game on the screen
and the niners and rams fans were all
going nuts every single time the bengals
were successful in a snap in a play in a
first down and a score and then in a win
i kept thinking to myself are you sure
this is the kid you won here or do you
want
the mahomes who this year has been up
and down do you want the guy who even in
this game
has shown
that the defense can sometimes confound
despite how generationally talented he
clearly is
do you want the kid who doesn't know
what he doesn't know yet
that that's the key right like i think
at this point the chiefs in mahomes
understand the reality of losing as well
as winning
like
the bengals don't know that at all like
they're not they're very reminiscent
actually rich of the 92 cowboys
who you know just sort of stumbled into
the postseason one year
and then in 92 they went to san
francisco with no expectations and they
beat
the 49ers at home
and then they just destroyed buffalo and
the super bowl they don't know anything
but success
so
they have they play like they're on
madden rookie mode at times you know
um the chiefs thing is interesting
because the one thing i've learned about
this season from start to finish is the
only team that can beat the chiefs would
be the chiefs
in 2021. like you're up 18 points at
home with patrick holmes you win that
game 99.999
of the time
the thing at the end of the first half
was the worst decision i've ever seen
mahomes make awful and he was clearly
not aware of the situation because he
tried to call timeout even though he
knew they didn't have a timeout but as
much as bad as the first the end of the
first half was the first series was
terrible for the chiefs
they got a terrible spot on that fourth
down call and they called timeout and
then they challenged well if they just
challenged and not called time out guess
what they have a timeout at the end of
the half
and they kick that field goal at least
and if they go up with that field goal
they probably win that game but going
off the half time of that game the
chiefs look like they were down 11 as
opposed to up 11 and the bank was like
we've done this already it's kind of
crazy yeah trey wingo here on the rich
ozin show caesars sports book chief
trends officer trey wingo the cto of
caesars here on the rich eisen show i
mean
what you just said though
and you're right yeah i'm not saying
you're wrong but what you just said is
you just said and this i think speaks to
what joe barrow has done yeah along with
the rest of jamar chase and burro and
everyone else and mcpherson who's got
ice in his legs man okay and mixon you
just said the bengals don't know
anything but winning you literally just
said that in the playoffs
like this is a team that that
four straight years finished in last
like the last team to do what they're
doing
is the 99 rams who won this trophy
that's sitting between us sir you know
so oh that's not a that's not a swag bag
thing this
you'll get a mug sir same thing the vlt
is not available on rich eyes and
shop.com
but you're right i mean like if for
example if they win sunday they will
have a faster turnaround than the
ultimate turnaround which was the
cowboys from 89 who went 1-15 to super
bowl champs back-to-back years they'll
do it faster than that team which is
remarkable
at this point they're playing with house
money they
they don't know anything but success at
this point these guys like joey said
like we're not underdogs we're really
good and sometimes when you've been to
where the chiefs have been where you've
been at the top you've been to the super
bowl you've lost one like
that is a that is a thing that
they don't have to deal with yet and i
think it's a huge mental advantage for
them trey wingo here on the rich eisen
show what are the
are the bengals more interesting to talk
about than the rams this week do you
think i mean the rams have a ton of
things to be talking about so the rams
are interesting because they're doing it
in the exact opposite way we're supposed
to do it like
les sneed whom i love treats first round
picks like spoiled potato salad get it
out of here it's been in the sun too
long you know i mean think about what
they did they traded two first-round
picks to get jared goff and then traded
jared goff and two more first-round
picks to get matthew stafford they're on
a run of going seven straight seasons
without a first-round pick
uh that's only happened one other time
one franchise the the washington
i mean i guess we call them the
commanders now but the other
reincarnations of washington under
george allen once won 11 straight years
without a first round pick the over the
hill gang and then when joe gibbs was
winning all his super bowls from 81 to
92 they also went seven straight years
without a first-round pick he's trading
first-round picks
for
a proven commodity ramsey uh you know
um they traded one for brandon cooks
they trade one away for brandon cooks so
i mean right now they have a 2024 first
round pick i'm under the complete
assumption that they won't be using it
exactly you know there's some freshmen
on campus right now thinking damn i'm
not gonna be a ram nope i'm gonna go
find me a five-year-old but he always he
he chafes it at this conversation though
because you know teams are built on
second night picks and now third day
picks that but that's why they're good
at this because cooper cup wasn't a
first-round pick right they find tyler
higby wasn't a first-round pick hell
bobby trees robert woods wasn't a
first-round pick so they what what
enables them to do what they do
is the fact that their scouting
department is so good because if they
weren't finding all these other players
in rounds two through seven and on
drafted free agents none of this would
work none of it it's a tr it's just a
testament to doing it a different way
and it proves the cap really any team
that says well we can't because of the
cap that's an excuse the cap is like a
bowl of jello it's completely malleable
and changeable you can take this money
over here and make it over here yeah
convert it to a signing bonus so it
doesn't like when the chief signed the
home to that half a billion dollar deal
they created cap space
they created cap space by giving a guy
allegedly 500 million dollars which by
the way which will be torn up in a year
or two and he'll get a 850 million
dollar contract
so here's the trend for you that i don't
know if it's a trend or not and i i
leave it to you to i guess bless it with
the
the blue check mark of of being a trend
yeah the last two nfc quarterbacks in
the super bowl
were
off-season acquisitions that everybody
was talking about because they were huge
big boom
off-season acquisitions and the concept
even when brady went to tampa is like
okay yeah yeah but can he win the super
bowl in his first year is he going to
win a super bowl there the answer is yes
yeah now at stafford when he was
acquired and that whole business when we
learned about what's going on at cabo
and then it was
that big trade with the lions that made
it official and
everyone's like yeah but can he really
win in the play who is matthew stafford
anyway and he's here they made it they
didn't and they actually even did the
bucks one better by not only eliminating
them yeah but hosting the nfc champion
which the bucks didn't do a year
so is that a trend do you think like the
next like is rogers is going to
basically say put me on the market you
know is it we're going to get like i
don't know how many segments you have
before but the aaron rodgers thing could
go for hours i mean we could do that but
it is
see this is and it goes back to my
premise yes like wins are not a
quarterback stat
teams win games you got you got stafford
on a better team guess what he won
playoff games he was in detroit they
were not a good team they lost playoff
games you know tom brady went to a team
that had
godwin that had evans they got antonio
brown and oh let's get that gronk guy
out of retirement right that might have
had some say in that defense as well
devon white shaq barrett that came over
from denver i mean like they went to
really good both of these guys went to
really good situations i'm not taking
anything away from their play but they
were dropped into pretty cushy
situations that allowed them to succeed
i mean remember the bucks last year were
seven and five
and that was remember the four fingers
with a thursday night game against the
bears tom
and then they didn't lose again and the
rams were kind of the same way you know
yeah they had that mid-season mid-season
slump and that was when robert woods
went down and odell came in by the way
apparently odell not the problem in
cleveland
um apparently that wasn't the thing
maybe it might have been some other
things
but you know you need to find a rhythm
and it's always that team that gets in a
rhythm late and it feels like the bucks
did that last year and the rams are
certainly in that rhythm now i guess
this super bowl for cleveland browns
fans right
can they if the bengals win when they
don't have to hear about odell and if
odell wins should be like yeah could
have had him and the bank
and the worst part the browns and the
lions are the the oldest two teams that
have yet to get to the party i mean the
other ones are you know the texans and
the jags they've only been around for a
while but well speaking of being around
for a while you got one more segment in
you i got a lot i appreciate you saying
come on cause you know i think it's like
one of those things like when you ask a
guest how are you doing like you know
what i've had a rough day yeah like you
really want to know i got a flat tire
my kids hate me well one thing the one
thing to help out with a flat tire is
the gift bag that you're going to get
when you walk out of it so i get an air
pump but not the trophy that's correct
got it there you go but the air pump
will have the rich eyes and show running
man logo on it what more do i need
actually i don't know do we have an air
pump chris can you look into that place
let me just make that happen will you
okay call your friend bezos 844 204 rich
is the number to dial right here on the
rich eisen show uh don't you dare go
anywhere more with traewing
uh put the photograph up that uh trey
just texted me who is that handsome
gentleman to the left right there that
is my father
or as he was called growing up sunny
okay
all right yeah see i'm i'm the third so
that's where the trade comes understood
um and that's us at sofi over the
weekend my dad uh was a reporter
for life magazine and covered the first
super bowl out here in los angeles yeah
so we did a whole thing on for that's
going to drop on caesar's channels and
on my feeds later on this week about the
difference between super bowl one and
super bowl 56 and
like his his famous line was like super
one
for life magazine they thought it was a
nothing burger you know i mean like what
are you going out there why are you
doing that right there were 30 000 empty
seats at the coliseum
it was on two networks cbs and nbc
because they wanted to get as much
attention as possible right um and like
nobody showed up and for life magazine
their thing was there need to be some
buzz some juice because you know a
newspaper is going gonna have the story
of the game the next day so they were
looking for
something that would sort of gravitate
uh people to read about the super bowl
and he filed a story and the
photographer sent some sense of some
photos in back to new york
and it didn't even make the addition
like that's how that's how the super
bowl was not a thing back then it didn't
even make the addition of life magazine
and talk about how things have changed
in this business yes
the whole life magazine philosophy was
let's cover 14 things
and maybe two will make the magazine
can you imagine that today no hey go go
get five shoots and maybe we'll use one
like that that just doesn't have no
because they'll just put it on their
tick-tock correct exactly
his recollections of that between also
the difference between so far in the
coliseum and it's just amazing how much
this thing has taken over us as a nation
like i think the super bowl is the only
thing a hundred million people in
america can agree on anymore is to sit
there and watch it sit there and watch
it
right there that's pretty neat yeah it's
fine
it's gonna be good it was really a blast
and uh he had a blast
we also got a his favorite car was a 67
mustang so we got a 67 mustang and drove
around la a little bit in it to talk
about stories no kidding yeah it was a
good time very rain man are you ah ten
minutes to wapner i'm an excellent
actually included vegas in it too
actually he said let's take it to vegas
i know a place where you go as a matter
of fact i don't think the owner of the
car is down with that
but it was fun we do brand had a good
time trey wingo here on the rich eisen
show netsuite by oracle is a sponsor of
the rich eisen show if you're ready to
upgrade go to netsuite.com rich we're
back here on our terrestrial radio
network one big happy family with our
peacock and sirius xm feeds with uh trey
wingo caesar's sportsbook chief trends
officer
um
so yeah how did you wind up with caesars
trey when you they knock on your door or
what happened here yeah it was a really
interesting story actually obviously uh
the supreme court ruling changes
everything and caesar's as an official
betting partner of the nfl
so i was you know happily doing the
other stuff the podcast writing for
facebook working for pro football
network and a bunch of other stuff and i
got a call from a guy that you and i
used to work with
john kosner okay dot com and he said hey
i have some people that want to talk to
you i was like well you know fine i'm
i'm really sort of in a happy place i'm
doing what i want to do and he's like
you're going to want to want to talk to
these people i'm like okay wow by the
way if that usually leads to a big wig
in vegas it doesn't end very well yeah
yeah someone's like vegas
somebody in vegas wants to talk to you
step in the car i think it would be to
your benefit to talk to these people it
doesn't end very well yeah i didn't have
to get in a car with two very large men
in gold necklaces okay uh it was a zoom
call a couple of people that's good that
uh that used to work with us at espn
what are these people uh sharon otterman
is your name she's the cmo of william
hill caesars and worked with me on espn
remember espn the phone
dude
right are you serious yeah that's that's
yeah espn the phone kids look it up it's
a dinosaur dude did you know that i
almost got one yeah
you're like you're that's why it didn't
work you almost got one did not get one
it was the early days of cell phones
like early 2000s i just wouldn't quit my
blackberry yeah by the way blackberry a
long time ago how much of the market
blackberry had and now they no longer
exist
so yes it's amazing how things work so
espn.com and espn the phone the phone
are are part of your your your history
and they they they wind up on a zoom
right yeah and uh
you know spence kramer do you remember
spence of course spence is part of this
jeff gagno
he owes me five bucks wow
i can get it from him i can get it from
them i'll see them later this week okay
so you know these were all guys that i
used to work people that i used to work
with espn so i'm basically doing the
same stuff for them that i did
uh at espn just doing it in a different
place on a different platform and then
uh kenneth's or kenneth of maine
this was the real deal sealer deal
sealer i think that works it's a phrase
that's bad let's make it work they said
it's trending yeah it's already trending
because you said it check there you go
um they said hey would you want to come
to
the to vegas and do a shoot with the
mannings and halle berry i was like
yeah i forgot jb smooth
yeah jb i said let me see give me i
think i could make that work yeah i
think i could do you fit it in your
schedule
so that was a good day it's been fun my
one halle berry story i'll tell it hey
i've got this one halle berry story
this was
great
that's a great story
i'll try and top it with mine
it's my only one chris
okay
it's not like i've got multiple halle
berry stories
you know me richard i'm down for any
hallelujah it's the story all right and
i'll hear it again
that's a smart man right there eddie
halleberry training what's that four
years ago five years ago yeah something
like that you know and i'm and i'm it's
my silly uh time of my my life when i
decided to actually train for my run
yeah and so uh i
i started to try and get into shape by
jogging yeah or jogging with a soft jig
you just run well whatever i was doing
and it's just like it's one of those
where i go three blocks wherever and i
gotta stop and it's just you know it's
not pretty it's it's you know my gait
isn't good and i'm like
heaving to get air and back into my body
it's not working out very well because
you know i'm probably going home and
have a soda but anyway so i'm i'm
running
and as i'm running and i'm just getting
ready to stop
i see holly berry pick up i guess her
kids at the corner at a bus stop being
dropped off and i just
sucked in my gut just found a second one
like forrest gump inspiration comes in
many forms as i run past i'm like
thinking to myself what am i doing this
for like what what could what is my end
goal like what like like what you're
doing
you're a dude so it's just you're a dude
that's what happened right you're a dude
so that's what happened to me it's just
like i thought like what did i think was
going to happen her children are there
it's not like all of a sudden like wow
who is that guy you know like i've got
to stop it and it's like there's no
follow-up there would be no file i don't
know what i was doing this is this is
how you are wired from the beginning of
time okay this is what it is hunter
gatherer reflex kicked in and that's my
holly berry story
you go okay
yeah so anyway
i do have a slight connection to halle
berry okay in 1986 does this involve
kevin bacon no it does not okay it
involves well that might involve kevin
bacon
actually doesn't everything involve
kevin bacon
i'm sorry i don't mean interrupt go
ahead so in 1986 halle berry was
runner-up miss usa
to a woman named christy fitchner okay
christy fitchner lived one street over
for me in greenwich connecticut
one street over and she went on to be
miss runner-up miss universe that year
okay in high school christy fitzner
dated none other than kevin bake no it
was young
steve young and christy fitzner were the
power couple at my high school greenwich
high school the rest of us never had a
chance so as i'm sitting at the chute
with hallie who was stunning as
cleopatra for
by the way seasons i saw the commercials
not terrible uh i figure i got one shot
okay so like you
yes you know
and i say straight and i say to halle
berry
if i say the words christy fitchner to
you
what do you say and she goes how do you
know christy fitchner
i was like well i'm like i'm in i'm in
i'm starting a conversation it worked
now yes and so i said well she grew up
with me blah blah blah oh i wonder what
she looks like now and i said i think
you won the long game is that what you
said to her
and that's how i got the picture she
said she was like oh that's very nice
you're getting a picture sure so that
was my end game just to get a picture
and it worked okay so thank you christy
wherever you are
put up a poll question uh whose halle
berry story is better
now
do you know what this reminds me of yeah
uh this reminds me of on friday
me bringing up to calvin johnson that he
lost
high school player of the year and
georgia to sean mcvay yeah and he said
what do you say something like there's
no damn way that that would actually be
the case or something like that i only
ever ever heard about this story after
after i made the hall of fame yeah after
mcbay got hired so you're telling me he
wasn't aware of it when he was in high
school is that what we're supposed to
believe that's what he said is that he
said is that what we're supposed to
believe he said he never basically had
heard of what he said yeah
there's no damn way there's no damn way
or something like that believe that
though well like sean mcveigh is his
with christy victor
fitchner yeah okay oh okay another sign
do you remember that horrible reality tv
show who wants to marry my dad
in the early 2000s christy fitchner was
a contestant on that show
halle berry's won the long game again
she won the long game pretty much and go
see moonfall it's out in theaters by the
way ladies and gentlemen i look at you
those commercials are funny they were a
blast and kenneth wheelock maine is
flying in i think as we speak is that
right he'll be here okay those are funny
cupper manning they're all there all all
there archie the spread must have been
insane right casino spreads i mean
casino spreads at a shoot have got to be
off the charts like there's not it's not
like some like bag of chips
and and water that's
there's got to be multiple styles of
water like right like what what what is
the casino style shoot we we shot it
spread look like at the top
villa on the top of caesars
the hangover suite no that's a different
hotel which i cannot discuss good job
good job
no it's not it would no no oh it might
have been yeah you're right i'm not
going to do it
come on
come on is this the real
this one i think was like 10 times that
size i literally think this villa was
about
6 500 square feet
on the top
of one of the towers that ceases
it was
it was insane it had fountains
it had inside inside it had in fact one
of the guys on the shoot knocked over
the fountain which is that one
yeah that was a good
one she took a header he took a header
uh but that that that shoot at that
villa was uh
chef's kiss go you get a caesars black
card
um
really not at liberty to discuss these
things
[Music]
chris and i were thinking about going to
vegas in a few
weeks oh sorry i lost your number
[Laughter]
it's not trending well
that's not trending
all right very good what was the first
sports center commercial you were in
i remember i remember mine what was
yours well i think it was in the
background of a bunch like the west side
story one do you remember that one you
were snapping your fingers snapping the
fingers i think i was were you on my
side or larry i think i was i think it
was on your side okay i think it was in
your side all right the one the one that
i remember obviously was the jerry
stackhouse one
um where you know he's laughing at my
name
i remember spence vance kramer
previously mentioned hey how do you feel
if we make fun of your name i'm like
i've had this name my entire life i'm
used to that so but the funniest part
for me about that if you go look at that
commercial they shot it in my little
cubby there right yeah and uh there's as
as you zoom in on jerry like laughing at
how stupid my name is there are the
pictures of my two kids on the
background when they were like five and
three oh boy and they're about to be 30
and 27. wow
yeah so i mean but it's it's one of
those things too i remember i remember
when they come up with ideas and you
just want to be in them in them i mean
guys i'm telling you when it was time
for a sports center shoot
a sportscenter commercial shoot it was
all about who's in it and why am i not
in more than that person correct and how
do i get in the ones that i'm going to
get in and they had like this book of
all the scripts in them and they would
just basically hold them like like a
like a poker hand directly to they do
not want you to say they want to see
because it was a very like they didn't
want anybody to know who was in them and
then when they finally start coming out
you'd be like wait a minute
why was i not on that one like there's
like six other anchors like why did they
choose these people to be and it was
very competitive well you liked each
other very much absolutely and then and
then when they would come to you with an
idea that's kind of like really do i
really want to do that you'd say you had
to do it like make fun of your name
correct uh hours when they sent you down
our three guest dan patrick
told like when i i got the script about
they're sending me down to the miners
now i i was very sensitive to the
subject that was like year three for me
or year four and i was trying i was
making a name for myself is there a
subliminal message they're sending it's
not just that it's just like i'm i'm all
about the branding yeah you know i mean
i've got the mug in the running man and
i'm all about branding that's what i'm
about okay and so i'm trying to brand
myself as a sports center anchor
worthy of the chair yeah next to dan or
when keith was there next to keith when
berman would would parachute in next to
him yeah like that's what i wanted to do
and i i i i thought it was being
successful so why would i want to have a
commercial because i'm sent down to the
mind but see here's the here's the
mental twist because we we know how good
you are rich this won't affect you well
right that's that's the that's the
executive
well they i didn't get any spen i was i
went to dan yeah because dan was the one
who fronted it yeah like he was the one
who's like you know
yeah he just sometimes
you know sometimes you gotta take a step
back right take a step forward and he he
he fronted the commercial he basically
told me he's just like get get out of
your head yeah cut cut the crap you know
it's funny this is a funny spot you're
gonna want to do it do the spot and then
i did it
and it's
you know it was great it's one of the
all-time greats where they sent me down
to james k polk high school and you know
and the kids are asking me to kind of mr
eisen can you buy some beer you know and
it is very very funny and i'm glad i did
it but at the time it was
you know dicey man your favorite spot of
mine was the ludovo one you see the the
go on my oh yeah go in the back there
like my kid eyes and uh
that was on
his shoulders or in on the back of the
chair in the green room when you this
when you the facial expression when you
sip the tea is just yeah perfect you
know who was not very happy about that
spot
take a guess who wasn't happy about that
[ __ ] probably imagine take it go
ahead and say it i'll confirm it stewart
correct there you go
stewart wasn't that thrilled about it
because he was just window dressing and
i was the guy i had the lines i had the
laugh lines and stewart would just have
to sit there and just be
the prop and stu was not happy about
that he was not a prop guy at all no
he's not a problem
i mean this was after he did with kenny
the commercial with kobe yeah and and
keyshawn and well jason williams
uh jake yeah jason williams and those
those are great spots and stewart's now
just got it so it's like so i got
anything stuart would just be like so
i'm just sitting here yeah but remember
times you would look at them and say so
i'm just sitting here yeah
just sitting there no
it's right i mean like that's true yeah
like this is the way and then there was
a but i was a prop and one that stewart
was in and i wasn't happy about it
either well
the one the one where he's in the
bathroom okay washing his hands correct
and the horse comes out but the but
before the horse comes out of the stall
yeah a referee a jockey comes out yes
and then i'm first yeah coming out of
the stall
without
washing my hands before leaving the room
yeah
because for
the sake of having to move the
commercial along they would not let me
wash my hands only stewart was washing
his hands and i'm like how come he gets
to wash his hands and i don't have to
wash my hands because it's because
everyone wants to know you're a
bacteria-ridden person so that's why one
of the one of the guys who was like the
one of the uh the a2s on it one of the
audio guys comes up to me as he's
putting the microphone on me after i'm
complaining they're like you know i'm
like just have the water running i'll
just pass my hands through it whatever
so the guy that they said no yeah and i
had to do it otherwise i was out of the
spot yeah that's uh and so you want in
or you want out it's pretty much what i
got yeah so i then said
i then was just steaming as they're
putting the microphone on me where i
have nothing to say just it's me coming
out of the stall and then walking out of
a stall
not standing at a urinal out of a storm
other things are going door stall
dropping
probably not writing a script so i'm
steaming and the guy puts the microphone
around as he puts some micro and he goes
you know it's more important to wash
your hands before you go into the
bathroom sometimes like that helps i
don't like it yeah thanks bro
i appreciate that yeah not helping
that's not really what we're going for
here but i appreciate that
commercial
a month later i'm at the world series in
yankee stadium and some guy screams hey
eisen how come you don't wash your hands
when you're coming out of the can i
swear to god it sounds like that guy was
set up dude it sounds like somebody set
you up because i was so upset about it
yeah yeah there were a few and stuart
was kind of like laughing the whole time
because he knew i was steaming about it
yeah and maybe he's thinking you know
back in that lou dover commercial they
should give me a line
because i throw you i'd throw you a
little lifeline here but he would just
sit there smiling and laughing as the
horse yeah it was in one of the new
buildings before then they put anything
in the horse took the hugest dump in the
middle of this
of of what was going to be a bustling
newsroom and the horse didn't wash his
hooves either
uh okay so what do folks need to know
about this super bowl from cesar sports
book service well listen we've done
trace trends all week long uh all season
long we're dropping a couple of episodes
of those
on youtube youtube caesar's uh youtube
channel sports uh instagram right uh
facebook on my social feeds um we gotta
like get the piece with my dad coming up
we also did a whole thing about the
super bowl and all the super bowl
history uh i'm sort of a
i don't want to say that i i i like to
think that i know a lot about the super
bowl if i have a better term but you've
covered a bunch of them yeah so it's
like my party trick some people can
whittle and yodel i can give you the
score
and the mvp of any super bowl it's okay
so we did a whole thing going through so
far just talking about all the games and
the scores and all that kind of stuff
okay it was fun all right and then
there's what what's your trend you want
to give anybody a little trend um you
got anything about what do you think's
gonna
bengal's plus four and a half uh what
yeah well that's that's the line uh i'm
gonna
way to get the minimum good job
uh
that's the pick people
oh okay that's your that you're
yeah i'll i'll make the official pick on
i'll do that on friday i'm i'm still i
told you guys
i told you guys
they're all like are you going to have
to tj go ahead say what you said to me i
was thinking socially we come you know
do a little thing where we get
everyone's picks
yeah people
like you trey thank you dan coming up
you're still formulating you have your
own this is content for you well it's me
and i i understand everyone and i will
happily share with you on friday
but just not content for me
i will happily send my pick into the
rich eisen yes here's my content for the
rich eisen show yes sir i will make a
pick on friday
or how about we just have trades like
say the bengals will win or the rams
will win and we'll just use whichever
take is right the winner is the bengals
pause the winner is the rams there you
go
we got it
one of those will work get the time code
it's going to overtime oh oh
oh
give it a shot
i don't know you know a guy in vegas you
know what i mean who knows get the top
floor in this thing all right you got
the photograph hoskins you want to pop
it up here pop it up here there you
go oh a halle berry selfie look at you
how smug yeah that that's the definition
of leap eating grin
i cannot believe she she said from
freeman halle buried as an age and then
you just coming over the
top do you ask for selfie how do you ask
for a selfie uh because the christie
fitchner story worked is that how it
works how it worked so they i i had it
in i had it open
we engaged and it wasn't just like hey
can i get a she's like oh sure because
you know we have that connection the
connection from greenwich connecticut
back thank you steve i appreciate you
buddy wherever you are steve young thank
you everyone what was he like in high
school very aloof
yeah like steve this is a true story we
we i did a half forgotten history
episode of the podcast
trey winkle presents check it out
wherever you get your podcast um and
like he admitted he he completed 41 of
his passes in high school
41
like he was a terrible thrower like he
could
grit young would be very upset about
that grit well if you remember greg
was a long long long way away and we
talked about that because like he didn't
know how to throw football until he went
to byu he went to byu as a defensive
back
because the offensive coordinator at the
time said to him i don't like lefties
and he was like okay
i don't like that i don't like lefties
or later perhaps you should like lefties
i'm assuming that oc didn't like
quarterbacks that can run very much or
that's byu so maybe they had to have
that i don't know but it was just a
disaster in fact this is another great
story i don't know where we are up
against the clock here go for it steve
young owes his career to sean salisbury
because steve again go forward steve was
a defensive back and they were going to
convert him to quarterback because they
had some people leave to go on their
mormon mission but they also said look
we've got this kid out of southern
california
who's mormon his name is sean salisbury
and if he commits to byu you're never
going to see the field
and he took he went to usc
now steve probably would have found a
way but like if so if sean salisbury
goes to to byu steve young's career
takes a completely different and more
circumlocutous path and i love things
like that like that little point in the
road changed his entire life very good
his entire life
and um it all starts and it all leads to
a selfie with uh
halle berry all roads lead to a selfie
with what did your what did your wife
think of the smug look on your face she
was like when you got that picture i
think she said i would have looked the
same way too
very good respect you're cleopatra your
own cleopatra there you go all right
trey wingo uh everyone check out uh at
wingo z uh tray.wingo on instagram your
youtube page for your trays trends uh
care of caesars sports book the chief
trends officer for said organization
trey wingo great to see you always a
pleasure my friend big time cheers to
everybody there you go everybody there
you go hit him straight too trey i'm
gonna try i know
i can't wait for your next selfie in
some beautiful spot give me ten days
there you go trey window everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here